andrew tate is banned from everything or
whatever he is banned okay meta
announced he's off instagram and
facebook both of his accounts have been
suspended now tick-tock and now
tick-tock
thoughts you know but does it stop
anything because it's not him posting
it's people posting
accounts accounts that are affiliated
with him or that seem to be promoting
his content online oh anything promoting
his content if his way of business
worked is that you would have an
affiliation yeah oh okay okay okay so if
you're taking course yeah exactly yeah
it was
hundreds of tape pages that's why so
many people are making the tape pages
because they can make money off yeah
it's like it's like a pyramid scheme
it's not a i don't know if it's a
pyramid scheme
mlm it's an mlm is the business term i
always hear but i thought that's
essentially a pyramid scheme where you
buy my course and then anybody you refer
to you get 50 of the money which is
actually a lot of money that's pretty
generous but then he gets 50 of
everybody you know what i mean so he
gets his share and he gets rich but
that's called a multi-level multi-level
marketing yeah i thought pyramid and
again i don't know but i thought pyramid
scheme is where like eventually someone
gets [ __ ] okay in this i don't think
anybody gets [ __ ] okay but it says if
it all falls out like the people at the
bottom once it gets big enough and they
can't reform refer more people if you
have to buy into it you're investing
money and you're losing money to buy
like the product up front but you still
get the course yeah and you're out what
200 bucks as opposed to bernie madoff
the pyramid schemes would be like more
and more money it'd be like obviously
bernie madoff's like your life savings
your pension or whatever world ponzi
scheme but that's a ponzi scheme that's
a little bit of pond right yeah maybe
that but even with this one it's like
if you're paying
to sell these things that seems like a
scheme but you're paying for access to
these course yeah i don't i don't think
that there's something immoral about
this that's why it's multi-level
marketing i think yeah and i don't think
that that's that bad if you had to buy
in so that you could sell that's [ __ ]
up because eventually you're saying you
run out of people to sell and now you're
paying for this thing that you can't do
yeah but if there's value in this thing
if and that's up to the person that's
purchasing it i don't think that that's
like i don't think he's like hurting
people well
yeah i don't think he's hurting people
by doing this that depends on what the
content is if the content is hurting
people then it's funny exactly yeah but
the the the the structure of the
business itself i don't think is like
taking advantage i was just going off of
the way hey hey you refer two people
then they refer two people and they
that's a pyramid you know what i mean
yeah yeah yeah that's why yeah yeah
schemer what's the scheme and that it's
a plan the scheme isn't a scam yeah it's
just like hey here's the way we're doing
this yeah plan of action yeah yeah i
don't know it's i mean like what a
fascinating i mean it's so [ __ ] smart
to take that to tick-tock this is an
idea that's existed multi-level
marketing or whatever it's called but
like to do that on tick tock honestly
you can hate his content all you want to
that idea is going to be replicated it's
already starting to be replicated by so
many people
i was looking at that like why and i
just make a bunch of fake accounts
posting my content the [ __ ] why didn't i
think of that yeah it's right there
smart move yeah yeah now they just
crushed his business
that's because the [ __ ] he's promoting
people don't like but if you're
promoting stand-up some people do like
it some people love it but a lot of
people don't like it yeah i guess that
the corporation is concerned about but
if you're promoting like a motivational
speech or something like that like a
tony robbins tony robbins exactly
would it work for tony robbins or does
it need to be this salacious
it helps it helps us being salacious it
helps to be selected but i think tony
robbins also those guys speak to
something internal like you're feeling
insecurity for the first time in your
life some people feel that more often
and when they hear motivational [ __ ]
that grabs them so if they do that and
it helps then they start promoting more
tony robbins content it'll grab not as
much but it'll still grab and grow yeah
i think just kind of salvation like if
you can be someone's guru and i think
for andrew tate a lot he was a lot of
people he was their guru yeah
yeah yeah i'm curious i'm curious what
happens with him
but yeah i that's my thing though is
like i don't love his content
but i also don't know if he should be
kicked off platforms
unless he's using the platform to do
crime
so like if he's using social media to
try to like recruit women for a webcam
thing that seems like quasi-illegal then
i can understand why the corporation
would be concerned but just for like
internet misogyny because obviously
misogyny is not good if he's being
serious like if it's a joke then it's a
different thing it's like artistic but
if he's being serious and like he's
being generally misogynistic yeah i
don't know if that's grounds i guess the
company could whatever they want because
they're private but like for me
personally i'm like is should that be
grounds i think the tricky thing is when
he starts like uh or someone in his
position starts affecting culture yeah
and i think that's probably what they're
concerned about i saw a conversation
i think it was i got a credit j jiddion
mm-hmm dion gideon gideon is that a
pronunciation
uh he had an interesting point about
uh
he goes
when kids go back to school you're gonna
see the
repercussions
that's the video that made because i've
always just it's funny and i didn't
think people took it seriously but then
i don't know if this is real or not but
some teachers saying like i teach
six-year-olds and you can hear the boys
saying like to girls like you're fat you
need to lose weight you don't have any
worth if you're not skinny and it's like
who knows of this guy yeah and you don't
know if it's true or not let me just say
the point that gideon was saying he was
basically saying like they're they're
it's summer right now so the kids aren't
at school
once they go back to school they're
going to be interacting with girls
and they're going to start saying the
things that they've heard yeah the red
pill [ __ ] that has gone across the
internet etc so now so whether or not
that's true that some teacher had that
tick tock and it's like oh [ __ ] if that
is true and that does happen that's sad
you don't want to see that [ __ ]
happening with kids man yeah i mean he
is the thing that makes him
so sticky is he's funnier than all of
those guys and he's a more unique
thinker in the sense that like the way
he can present his ideas yeah you
haven't heard him present also a lot of
it is yes he's not dumb like a lot of
what he says like will have semblances
of truth but it's also tied in with like
crazy vitriol and like lies or things
like that that i think would make people
frustrated yeah i mean yeah or it's like
inflammatory it's intentionally
inflammatory it's intentionally
inflammatory but yeah they're you can
say something that's true that's like
not uh
i don't want to call it disgusting but
like it's unfortunate there's a lot of
truths that are unfortunate yeah
all right guys we're gonna take a break
from this exclusive patreon clip because
i got to tell you all about surf shark
surf shark is a modern vpn designed with
a user in mind their utilities are
powered by robust security mechanisms
but designed to be simple and intuitive
to use enjoy all the freedoms of an open
internet safely and anonymously with no
device limits
think about this strictly no logs means
that they don't keep your data you can
unlock the 15 largest netflix country
libraries including the us and japan by
merely connecting to a server in the
right country okay also reach your
favorite sites and services even in
countries that ban them as surf shark
bypasses censorship and geoblocking to
give you access to facebook in china or
tick tock in the u.s and remember this
there's a 30-day money-back guarantee
which gives users plenty of time to try
out surf shark risk-free that's how
confident that they are that you're
going to love it so right now get 83 off
a two-year plan and three extra months
for free go to
surfshark.deals
schultz that's s-c-h-u-l-z and use the
code schultz s-c-h-u-l-z to get 83 off a
two-year plan and three extra months for
free protect yourself online today now
let's get back to this exclusive patreon
clip join our patreon patreon.com
flagrant a lot of truth is unfortunate
and there's and that's the problem when
like you try to like
create a society i don't want to say
it's like exists on lies but sometimes
the wokeness goes to a point where it's
like we are we all know we're kind of
lying and it's okay that we're lying
because it allows society to be
lubricated
exactly right so it's just like yeah we
should be more accepting we should do
all these things this is good and then
there's an extreme to that where you
have like obese models and it's like
okay we all know that that's not the
ideal makeup for a woman's body yeah we
all know that's not healthy yeah right
not that skinny models are super healthy
but they're they're just as unhealthy
and we have conversations about this is
too skinny yeah we said this is this
[ __ ] gross but the acceptance gets
morphed into a
what's more than acceptance
it's almost like a manipulation tactic
yeah so it's an intolerance of anybody
pointing out logical things yeah so it's
almost like and you see these figures
pop up when this happens and i wonder if
like you could even chart it it's like
trump can only exist
if
politicians become so fraudulent
right yeah he comes out and he's like a
beacon of light yeah like he's just
talking normal when all these people are
doing their like little talking points
and
when they start to go in the talk like
listening to ted cruz and donald trump
talk on the same stage it's like one of
the most
like mind-boggling experiences i've ever
seen because
you're it's like you're watching a
cartoon and then
a person
yeah do you know what i'm saying like
you're like it's just like what has
happened like does he really think that
that's how you communicate to people
yeah i'm talking about like the ted cruz
yeah i think that hard-working american
da da da da and this guy's like what are
you talking about his wife's fat yeah
you're like
yeah it's like who framed roger rabbit
it's like how do humans and cartoons
exist in the same world
uh trump is not being fully authentic
and saying fully honest things but he
speaks to that lizard brain part of us
that primal part of us yeah in a way
that breathes just as much [ __ ] yeah it
reads way more authentic than this guy
you look at that guy and you're like
that guy's a product yeah and this guy
is speaking to me on an emotional level
that seems way more authentic than this
yeah it's like when you see like a
shitty comic go up and or like a good
comic go up and then a shitty one
follows it and all of a sudden like
everything you see from that comic just
seems like yeah so
fabricated and like structured and
you're just like
ugh yeah now if you didn't see that good
comic go before you'd be like oh this is
funny that was good a little
misdirection thing or that was cute but
once you saw the reel yeah it's hard now
obviously with trump yeah he's spouting
[ __ ] too yeah but
something happens about that it's like
you can't extend the things that we all
know not to be true too far
yeah because it opens up the door
for
these types of people the trumps the
tates
does that make sense yeah i think the
same group of people that are creating
tate that are the hey you have to accept
everyone everything is okay if you have
any problem with any of this you're a
monster yeah that created tate i think
that also created trump not just fake
politicians but everybody's like no you
have to tolerate everything white men
are born evil there's nothing you do to
help but we got books saying white
people are inherently evil that seems
crazy so when one guy comes along and is
like yo
you're not inherently evil yeah they're
like oh and they'll [ __ ] all this
tolerance they're like yo that guy
that's my guy i've been waiting for some
and even i i say this in a bit of mine
but like it festers and it gets dark and
it gets angry because you don't get to
let it out ever and express it and then
he he's saying in the angriest way
speaks to your how dark it's gotten yeah
so then what should we do what is like
the well that's my thing it kind of
tolerates an intolerance blanket
censorship with that kind of thing like
i feel like we'll just draw more
attention in the short term and maybe in
the long term it washes it out
completely but i'm like if you're a
social media company and you don't want
to have certain people posting on your
platform i don't know why and again i
don't know if there's ethical but just
from their perspective why not just like
silently throttle
you know what i mean like i do but i'm
saying like why not just do that with
all of like all like tate content let's
say instagram doesn't like his content
and they're like just makes it look like
and yeah and like tic tocs like they're
like oh we don't want 12 and 15 year
olds going to school like listen to this
[ __ ] so let's just take his content off
like the algorithm is strong enough that
they understand who's talking and what
content is it's like they can just
throttle it and take it off of it
then you kind of galvanize him if he's
still
able to be on the platform and he's
obviously being throttled now it's like
um you're going to champion all his fans
like yo look we're going to go even
harder now but i guess how can you prove
that sounds obviously being throttled i
mean if you're just like oh yeah your
condo is not hitting the same you're not
you haven't changed they talk in
particular you got no control over how
that algorithm you just put some [ __ ] up
and you're like i guess this goes i
guess this doesn't i've heard everybody
say maybe not you as much but they're
like there's so many videos i thought
would go crazy and then did not and so
many random videos i thought wouldn't do
anything like crazy none of us get the
algorithm so tick tock can throttle the
easiest yeah but i think with somebody
like him you kind of have to just remove
it all together because like especially
if his
game plan is getting people to repost
this [ __ ] it's never going to die down
unless it's off
yeah because it's not even coming from
his account yeah i mean that's the
beauty to his for you know for his
system is that if you block him it does
nothing yeah yeah he doesn't post any of
these videos yeah i'm not going online
for it yeah so you've got it you kind of
have to throttle or cancel i guess the
greater question is what he's saying
grounds to take him off the platform i i
don't know everything he said i've heard
a couple of things that are just like
yeah it's crazy yeah but it's like i
don't know what the consequence is
i don't want to get into like telling
people they can't say whatever they want
etc especially if they're like doing it
with a sense of humor but uh and i
haven't heard everything that tate said
but he has said some really funny
[ __ ] things i think it's just
interesting that like
this is always the reaction to extreme
wokeness yes right and i'm sure you look
at history like
extreme intolerance probably creates the
same
version yeah like there's a tate that is
extremely accepting and welcoming and
kind
you know and i wonder if like that's
hippie movement in the 60s
is the hippie in the movement 60s comes
right after
like this is the generation of kids that
grew up
and were born world war ii yeah right
yeah so this is post-world war ii super
conservative nuclear family segregated
super repressed intolerant to everything
all of a sudden the hippies they're
intolerant to exactly free love for
everybody yeah the parents are coming
back these dudes are shell-shocked they
don't even know how to [ __ ] hug their
kid they're just waking up in the middle
of night screaming yeah drinking their
[ __ ] asses off and all of a sudden i
love you i love everybody it is what it
is so i guess it always swings okay but
so maybe the version
to control this if we're like
constructing society is like it's
censorship on the extreme of both ends
once you start like positioning obese
chicks as like healthy
then you're part of these social media
companies go yo i think we gotta cancel
some of these obese chicks or healthy
accounts
because if we let that go on too long
then we're going to have these
[ __ ] that come up and they're
just like [ __ ] you're fat shut the [ __ ]
up stop eating donuts yeah right and on
the other side you know if intolerance
is getting too popular we got to cancel
some of those accounts because then all
of a sudden these hippies are going to
come i mean the the accounts that are
like yo white people are born evil
that's just who you are yeah that's
intolerance you can cancel that you have
grounds to cancel that right the pro and
i think the reason they make these
things public honestly is it quiets down
outrage against us it's all [ __ ] pr
for all of these companies yeah you have
billions of dollars on the line yeah you
have just constant pr advertisers so i
could silently ban andrew taylor
throttle andrew tate but then i don't
get the pr of saying hey we ban andrew
tate oh you think they want the pr i
think they want the pr saying we did the
right thing and the same way yeah
they're sorry to interrupt but you're
saying they're being criticized for
allowing it on the platform so they need
the pr boost and by canceling all right
funnels and like that kind of thing what
is that or oh you're funneling people
all right this idea
like that like oh like your red pill you
know funny tick tock clip is actually a
wormhole into joining you know it's
funny you're not seeing green we were
talking about this a little bit before
what is funny is that like a lot of
these kids are just experiencing things
that like young adults experience and
unfortunately they're getting like
rewarded for it
and they're not they may not have the
time to like evolve and then grow out of
it you touched on this with the freshman
fit yeah guys right and you thought that
they were a little bit old they should
have evolved and grown out of it but
maybe maybe they reached at a later time
because their maybe development was
stunted from stuff you know when they
were
but yeah i think guys go
through a frustrating time
where the ideology of of tate or the
ideology of certain people in the
manosphere makes a lot of sense to them
i mean i definitely felt it when i was
younger it's like the thing that you
want more than anything
is not in your control at all
like you want to get laid right maybe
that wasn't exactly the same with you
guys i still wanted the validation of a
pretty girl that i want to marry or
whatever yeah and and that that at its
core is like very real i think all dudes
can relate to this like we want these
girls to validate us and then the
feeling of either not being good enough
not having enough resources i'd imagine
if you look at
the people that are into the manosphere
stuff it's like
younger ish guys who probably are not
that financially secure yeah nobody with
like tons of money and success is
tapping into the manosphere stuff
because it's like well you're getting
[ __ ] and at the end of the day
i either want to find out how to get
[ __ ] or i want a reason why girls
aren't [ __ ] me
so it's either here's the trick to get
laid or
see these [ __ ] all they care about
are these things and those things are
horrible and i don't have them so [ __ ]
them they're a bunch of money hungry
[ __ ] or even like what mark said
which i thought was really pointed on
that episode is i feel like you guys are
good guys who got like played played by
girls or whatever and then you get hurt
and then your reaction is oh it's not my
fault these women are x y and z [ __ ] all
of them and and i think what happened
at least i know it's happened with me i
know for a fact happened with you and
you and you i imagine as well
is like
you get a little bit older and it was
probably later for me
than you guys well definitely but uh
you get a little older and then you find
like a great like woman yeah and it's
really hard to harbor any animosity yeah
like you can still see women being
annoying we're gonna have jokes about
women just like we're gonna have jokes
about [ __ ] latinos we're gonna have
jokes about everybody everybody gets
these jokes but the feeling of i am
completely
powerless in the ability to get
validation from this group of people
that means so much to me right you have
that woman that loves you more than
anything in the world and all of a
sudden you're not out here trying to
stump and fight and you know you know
the men are killing themselves every day
yeah you get the feeling earlier yeah
but you will grow out of it my concern
is
are people like tattooing themselves
by becoming famous
by red pilling and becoming like a
famous red pill guy you you're
eventually going to evolve out of it it
happened yeah i went through you look at
even my earlier stand up yeah i didn't
go through it through i'm gonna rant on
this [ __ ] look into a stream and
rants like i created art out of it but
you eventually evolve out of it
what happens now that you have thousands
of videos of you on the internet saying
these things that you won't believe in
two years you're gonna have a girl that
you love and you're gonna look back and
you're like what the [ __ ] was i thinking
i was just insecure and i wasn't getting
the girls that i want to get and there
was hotter chicks i think i deserved but
they weren't showing me any attention or
love they were just dating these crypto
guys like
now that thousands maybe tens of
thousands of videos exist of you on the
internet saying the worst thing
that's a tattoo man yeah not to mention
if you build an audience around in your
financial sustainability is dependent on
it can you go on that one
okay i've built a manusphere audience
where all of my audience wants me to
talk [ __ ] about women yeah and now i've
obviously got married i had a daughter i
don't view women in the way that i used
to but my audience wants me to keep on
saying this [ __ ] you have a lifestyle
built around the money that's coming in
from that audience do i pivot and try to
turn a different direction and try to
pull some of the audience with me
inevitably a lot of them will fall off
and find the next person if they haven't
grown up with me in the same way and
then i lose that percentage of my money
or i just implode my whole audience all
together and like that's really scary
especially because the time that you're
doing it is once you've built a family
so it's like now i have a family
and i gotta support my family now i'm
about to be as financially unstable as
i've ever been because i'm turning my
back on my audience that has built me up
and if you don't now your wife is all
embarrassed you got to answer these
questions every two seconds like how do
you deal with the crazy things these
guys so now you got to hide your wife
and your kids from the world so they
don't got to deal with the fact that
you're being fraudulent because if you
really believe in that [ __ ] run it up
yeah you know what i mean have her
defend it yeah it's i i am i am
i wonder if people
the one of the great things about the
internet is we get to put our art out
there we get to put our comedy out there
we get to put our content podcast have
so much fun
one of the tricky things about it is it
it's it's on the blockchain now yeah
like your evolution is there
and it might be harder to evolve if one
your finances are back to these beliefs
that you will grow out of 100 you will
grow out of yeah and if you don't grow
out of them then maybe you never
and maybe you never found that person
that
is going to love you in a way that you
didn't know that you could be left i
think you
and
the people we i think put more value and
authenticity than a lot of people yeah i
think most of social media is an
inauthentic version of ourselves just to
try to get validation or money or
whatever so i don't think these guys are
as concerned about being inauthentic
when they evolve when they grow whatever
they deal with that they hide their wife
they hide their daughter they don't talk
about it they just make their videos
they don't care about being authentic
they just want validation fame money a
lot of them everybody wants it yeah yeah
we wanted to and i think on this podcast
we try to be authentic through stand-up
we try to be authentic